les faits se sont déroulés devant ces
deux discothèques le manhattan en plein
centre ville de fort de france le 6 mars
dernier à l'aube aux environs de 5
heures un jeune homme de 19 ans touché
dans une fusillade prise en charge par
les secours
décédé des suites de ses blessures les
premiers témoignages permettait
d'obtenir quelques éléments je dors et
déjà une certaine lagoueyte et puis à la
fin énergie de veilleuses de boissons et
puis négligé mais j'ai par jean orizet
ses services allaient il à dire l'anc
est diligentée par le parquet de
fort-de-france permettait de remonter la
piste d'un individu de 25 ans né en
france
l'homme est connu du parquet il avait
déjà été condamné en martinique en 2014
et 2018 pour des faits de vol en réunion
et de violence avec arme ce dépositaire
de l'autorité publique
à l'issue de la fusillade il était
localisée en thaïlande
ce n'est que le 20 mai dernier qu'il
sera interpelle en france plus
précisément à versailles selon le
parquet de fort de france
le taux d'élucidation des homicides est
en nette progression
par exemple je prenais les chiffres de
2018 où nous avons eu quand même à
déplorer
dix huit homicides volontaires parmi ces
18 il ya déjà 10 à ce jour qui ont pu
d'ores et déjà faire l'objet d'une
liquidation c'est à dire des individus
qui aurait pu être présentée aux
autorités judiciaires sur ce début
d'année 2010 9 nous avons déjà à
déplorer 10 homicide volontaire et parmi
ces 10 il ya déjà six qui ont pu être
élucidés et je peux vous assurer de ce
que les services d' enquête travaillent
d'arrache-pied d'arrache-pied pour
permettre donc l'élucidation des
dossiers qui ne sont pas encore à ce
jour élucidées à la sude mandat d'amener
le présumé meurtrier du jeune homme de
19 ans a été déféré devant un magistrat
instructeur 25 mai dernier mais en
examen pour homicide et les places en
détention provisoire à ducos